it's usually the animals that die first
in this region inhabited largely by
ethnic Somalis the goats cows and camels
have already perished after that
children are often not far behind in
eastern Ethiopia over five million
inhabitants live as nomads moving across
the land with their animals but the
drought has ravaged both livestock and
people the luckier ones about 4000
people have made their way to kibrit de
ha a temporary settlement managed by
UNICEF this woman says she's lost all
her animals and she's come here with her
ten children for shelter more refuge
will come will come soon unless the
spring rains started in this drought
affected areas dwindling water supplies
are the biggest problem people explain
to the German Development Minister how
they long for the 15th of April when the
rainy season usually begins water is now
only obtainable at great depths and
drilling wells is costly trucks with
tanks are distributing water throughout
the region almost 10 million Ethiopians
are affected by the water shortage
Ethiopia footing half the bill for the
humanitarian aid what they require from
us is the humanitarian community and
from the United Nations is really
technical assistance to ensure that
we're bringing in new approaches to
identify deep groundwater develop that
deep groundwater using private sector
contractors and then ensure the
appropriate operation and maintenance of
the infrastructure once it's once it's
built the last time drought struck the
country Ethiopians learned the
importance of proactive measures such as
soil conservation and the recovery of
grazing areas but without help from
abroad the effects of the drought will
be felt far beyond Ethiopia especially
if the u.s. under the trump
administration cuts funding for
humanitarian aid the pitar of to dig is
something given this dramatic situation
this whole zone on the Horn of Africa
needs 4 billion euro
but just 1 billion is available so far
that means emergency provisions for
families will soon run out because we
the wealthy industrialized countries in
Europe aren't prepared to show more
solidarity and help out leave bedight
Sania solidarity to tighten Munna is
especially concerned when he sees medics
measuring children's upper arms a yellow
band means a child has a chance of
survival a red band means the child's
malnutrition is life-threatening